هنا في برونت غير نشا كريم مصطفى بن زنا
افضل لاعب كره قدم في العالم حي متواضع
وفقير بل تصنفه السلطات الفرنسيه على انه
خطير امنيا لكن هنا لا مظاهر امنيه بل فرح
عارم عبر عنه السكان بهذا الرسمي العملاق
لابن الحقيقي بعد نيل كريم الكره الذهبيه
غدا الحي مقصدا لكثير من الناس و لفنانين
راب الشباب ايضا
[موسيقى]
في السابعه من العمره
فوتبول
في طفولته كان كريم يتدرب على جدار في
النادي اصبح اليوم مثل تعويذه للاعبين
الصغار وكان السبب الذي دفع صائد اللاعبين
في نادي ليون العريق لترق باب العائله
وعرض اول عقد الاحترافين عليه
[موسيقى]
افضل هداف فرنسي
وفي امم اوروبا افضل لاعب في العالم وصاحب
الكره الاثمن الكره الذهبيه القاب يفخر
بها بنزيما وترسم فرحا غامرا على وجه كل
من عرفه طفلا صغيرا قبل 27 سنه ونجما
كبيرا في عالم كره القدم اليوم
فادهوك العربيه اليوم